Le confinement le plus strict doit encore se poursuivre jusqu'au lundi 11 mai
Yes le mec sait mettre l'ambiance quand même hein ?
ça va vous ?
Bon on le savait ... hein ? Mais quand même ce genre de trucs, on a beau s'y attendre quand même quand ça arrive
ça fait pas plaisir ... hein? Alors là le truc en plus c'est que la nouvelle elle tombe un petit peu à un moment où
j'ai l'impression que tout le monde était un peu dans le creux de la vague
non ? Je sais pas si c'est le cap des 1 mois de confinement
si c'est cette espèce de date butoir du 15 avril qu'on avait depuis le début, même si on savait que ...
Enfin je sait pas ce qu'il y a, mais en tout cas ... j'ai eu l'impression qu'il ya une espèce de baisse de
d'entousiasme
généralisée dans ce mouvement
bah c'est vrai que ça dure un peu quand même cette histoire maintenant la même si au début on avait tous pleins d'idées super sympa
pour meubler
pour tout ça. Mais en plus le truc c'est qu'on tenait tous plus ou moins le coup en se disant qu' à la fin on allait tous
se retrouver et que ça allait être la fête du slip et puis que de toute façon au pire y aurait l'été pour se rattraper
et puis plus ça va plus on se rend compte que
la sortie ça n'a pas vraiment être qu'on s'imaginait au début hein ? Qu'il va falloir rester
hyper prudent qu'il va y avoir encore des règles à respecter
puis que l'été
Restaurants, cafés et hôtels
cinémas, théâtres, salles de spectacles et musées
resteront en revanche fermée à ce stade . Yes Manu, tu m'aides pas beaucoup la hein? Vraiment.
Bon bah alors du coup on fait quoi ? Je veux dire on n'a pas le choix on oublie de rester enfermé
la bonne nouvelle quand même c'est qu'on a fait plus de la moitié hein ?
mais c'est quand même pas la fête j'avoue, du coup qu'est ce qu'on fait pour pas péter les plombs
Attention là on va pas parler des cas de figure où il ya des éléments très concrets
et très immédiat qui font que le confinement se passe mal ou très difficilement
comme des problèmes de santé par exemple ou des histoires de violence au sein du foyer
pour tout ça je vous remets dans la description les liens utiles pour savoir comment agir dans ces situations là
on va pas non plus parler des gens qui continuent à travailler, par contre ces gens là une nouvelle fois on va leur dire encore
merci, un grand merci parce que c'est grâce à eux si, 1) on va s'en sortir, 2)
2) on continue à vivre pendant ce temps là, là aujourd'hui on va vraiment parler des gens qui sont
confinés
et qui le vivent mal. Voilà ces gens là ils ont pris un parpaing sur le coin de la tronche quand ils ont appris que
le confinement ça allait durer encore un moment
et ils se demandent comment ils vont faire pour tenir le coup.
J'ai envie de vous dire : "La vie c'est pas attendre que l'orage passe, la vie c'est apprendre à danser sous la pluie"
C'est Sénèque qui à dit ça.
Et comme Sénèque c'est quand même pas la moitié d'un con,
on va lui faire confiance et on va essayer d'apprendre à danser sous la pluie
C'est une métaphore. Donc pour ça on va d'abord essayer de comprendre pourquoi on est mal
et même avant ça on va déjà commencer par se dire un truc
on a le droit
d'être mal. Hein je veux dire ce qu'on est en train de vivre c'est un truc historique, c'est du jamais vu dans l'époque moderne,
donc on a plein de raisons d'être mal.
ça veut pas dire qu'il faut rien faire pour aller mieux, ça veut dire qu'on peut déjà commencer par se débarrasser
de la culpabilité ne pas aller bien
parce que la culpabilité
ça ne sert à rien et ça fait pas du bien. On va déjà à s'enlever ce poids de nos épaules l'a déjà on se
sentira tout de suite plus léger et puis ça va nous permettre d'avancer et de faire ce qu'il faut pour aller mieux.
Alors ce que je vous propose, cette culpabilité on la prend, on la malaxe, on en fait un petit bol
et ont fait caca dedans ... et après on jette tout ça et on tire la chasse, le bol est biodégradable, vous pouvez y aller.
Métaphores, encore. Déjà ça devrait aller mieux, mais on va passer à la suite, alors en plus de toutes les raisons individuelles
qu'on a de pas bien vivre le confinement, que ce soit des raisons personnelles, des raisons professionnelles, des raisons financières.
il ya deux grandes causes, qui fait qu'on est mal dans cette situation, en ce moment.
D'abord on n'est pas bien parce qu on subit. On subit la situation et du coup on attend.
On attend que l'orage passe si vous voulez.
Et ensuite on n'est pas bien parce que on sait pas
on ne sait pas quand l'orage va s'arrêter et on sait pas à quoi ça va ressembler dehors quand l'orage sera fini.
Le truc de Sénèque toujours. ça c'est des trucs qui sont hyper classique, hyper connue.
L'ignorance, le fait de pas savoir, ça génère de la peur.
"La peur mène à la colère, la colère mène à la haine, la haine ...
mène à la souffrance."
et la peur ça génère de l'hostilité
C'est pour ça par exemple qu'on nous explique, pourquoi le train est coincé en plein milieu de la voie, quand ça nous arrive.
Alors ça nous empêche pas d'être vénère parce qu'on est coincé, mais au moins on arrête d'angoissé quand on sait pourquoi.
Et on est "vener" parce qu'on subit,
justement. On a cette impression qu'on peut rien faire et le sentiment d'impuissance c'est un truc qu'on gère pas très bien, en général.
Sauf qu'en vrai il y a plein de trucs qu'on peut faire. On peut pas ... arrêter la pluie, mais on peut apprendre à danser dessous.
ça fait beaucoup de métaphores croiser là d'un coup hein ?
"Mesdames, messieurs, suite à l’arrêt de notre train pour une durée indéterminée, nous sommes immobilisés jusqu'à ... on sait pas quand."
Bon, mais bref... Vous avez l'idée, l'ignorance et l'impuissance c'est les raisons pour lesquelles on est inquiet
angoissé et en colère.
Maintenant qu'on a planté le décor on va décliner sa de façon un petit peu plus concrète. Bon pour le côté vénère déjà
on est d'accord c'est ... ça soulage, y a pas de mal à se soulager.
Le truc c'est que si ... ça devient une habitude sur le long terme,
on rentre vite dans une espèce de spirale négative qui nous fait pas du bien. Donc
première chose on va arrêter de s'énerver après des trucs contre lesquels on peut rien ... et cette énergie
qu'on a économisé, on va la mettre en oeuvre pour faire des trucs
constructifs.
Genre apprendre à danser sous la pluie.
On va y revenir après. Pour l'impuissance maintenant, pour contrer ce côté subi là.
L'idée c'est d'arrêter de se dire: "On me force à rester enfermé chez moi", mais c'est plutôt d'essayer de se rappeler pourquoi
rester chez soi c'est le meilleur moyen de soulager les hôpitaux
et le personnel soignant qui en chient déjà pas mal, c'est le meilleur moyen de protéger les personnes
les plus fragiles et c'est aussi le meilleur moyen de faire en sorte que cette épidémie
s'arrête.
Une fois qu'on a réussi à faire ça, une fois qu'on a réussi à redonner du sens au confinement et à se dire que c'est
une façon positive
d'agir, on peut se réapproprier le truc et se dire: "c'est ça qu'il faut faire,
donc c'est ça que je fais". Voilà c'est une espèce de façon d'être dans l'action,
donc on subit plus.
Maintenant pour cette espèce d'angoisse qui est née du fait qu' on sait pas ce qui va se passer et qu'on sait pas comment ça
va se passer.
Déjà maintenant on a une date.
Le 11 mai, même si on sait maintenant d'expérience que c'est le genre de chose qui peut changer, parce qu'on était sur le 15 avril,
même si on n'y croyait pas trop.
Le truc c'est qu'il faut bien garder à l'esprit que les gens qui décident,
ils sont comme nous, ils savent pas comment ça va évoluer, ils savent pas comment ça va se passer.
Du coup, le déconfinement on sait pas concrètement non plus comment ça va se passer pour les mêmes raisons, donc on sait pas.
On va accepter ça, on ne maîtrise pas l'avenir, on va se concentrer sur la seule chose qu'on maîtrise un petit peu ici et maintenant.
On vit dans l'instant présent,
un jour après l'autre, un petit peu comme si on était au pied d'une montagne qu'on devait escalader et qu'on voyait pas le sommet.
Si on passe notre temps à regarder tout en haut
on va avoir le vertige, on va voir floue, on va avoir la tête qui tourne, on va saigner du nez et on va se décourager.
Alors l'idée, c'est de regarder là où on va mettre la main,
la prochaine prise, là où on va mettre le pied et ainsi de suite. Une prise après l'autre, et bah voila, pareil.
Encore une métaphore, je suis ... je suis "on fire". Bon ça c'est pour la théorie mais du coup en
pratique comment on fait ? Parce que je vous vois là, vous êtes embêté, il ya plus de farine chez Franprix, vous avez fini Tiger King,
vous avez relu tout
Alfred DE MUSSO, vous ne savez plus quoi faire, vous vous ennuyez. Alors si vous êtes du genre à avoir besoin de créer, de faire des
trucs qui font du sens, qui laissent une trace, qui s'inscrivent dans la durée. Parfait, très bien, continuez à mener à bien vos projets,
continuez à apprendre des trucs, parfait. Pas de pas de souci avec ça. Juste, c'est pas du tout obligé
d'être productif, de créer des trucs etc ... On n'est pas tous pareils à ce niveau là,
c'est très très bien comme ça. On a dit qu'on arrêtait de se culpabiliser, donc on se fout la paix et on se retire un petit
peu de la pression et tout ça.
Un conseil qui est valable pour tout le monde par contre, en ce moment, l'idéal c'est de fonctionner à l'envi.
Pour se sentir bien, le top c'est de se blinder de sérotonine,
d'endorphines, de plein de trucs en "ine". Et pour ça, la règle:
Faites-vous du bien, faites vous plaisir.
"...branlement,
intime"
Oui, si si, non mais si si, ça ça marche.
Mais il ya d'autres trucs aussi, alors quoi d'autre ?
La difficulté à ce stade, c'est un petit peu ce qu'on a dit, c'est qu'on a peut-être fait un petit peu le tour de ce
qu'on avait prévu de faire. Parce que ça fait déjà un mois quand même.
Alors s'il ya des trucs qui marchent toujours, là on change pas une équipe qui gagne
continuez. Mais, si vous avez du temps à meubler et que vous avez pu trop d'idées ...
l'idée c'est de ne pas laisser la routine s'installer.
Vous savez ça mieux tout le monde, la routine c'est la daronne de la lassitude.
On n'a pas besoin de ça en ce moment. Donc, déjà un premier truc,
vous avez sûrement constaté ça, quand on commence à mâchouiller son somme, on a tendance à se coller dans des espèces de boucles.
C'est les mêmes trucs qui tourne en rond dans notre tête sans arrêt, on fait et on refait les mêmes choses
machinalement, de façon cyclique, sans vraiment y prendre de plaisir. On est un peu coincé.
Donc déjà quand on repère ça, il faut péter la boucle. Dans
99% des cas à ce moment là on est passif. Donc, déjà, première chose, on se lève et on fait un truc.
On range, on fait du ménage, on fait des pompes, on va se laver les dents, on tape un petit moon walk, on fait n'importe quoi,
du moment qu'on fait autre chose que ce qu'on était en train de faire. Et une fois qu'on a cassé la spirale,
ou peut passer à un truc qui va nous faire plaisir. Et là, mes deux petits conseils pour bien casser la bouche à la routine,
picorer et se surprendre. Se surprendre en partant du principe qu'on a déjà fait tout ce qu'on avait prévu de faire,
eh ben c'est faire des trucs qu'on n'avait pas prévu de faire. Voir qu'on a jamais fait. Ne serait-ce que juste pour essayer,
pour voir si on aime ça. Et on peut se surprendre même si on est confiné solo hein !? Alors en allant fouiner sur internet, vous connaissez,
en demandant aux potes ce qu'ils font eux, ça peut donner des idées, ou alors en jouant à un petit jeu,
que j'ai inventé personnellement et que j'appelle le jeu de l'exorciste. C'est à dire en pivotant
la tête de cette façon.
Voilà vous tournez la tête, vous regardez autour de vous et votre regard va s'arrêter sur des trucs qui vont vous donner des idées.
Genre ...
Vous tombez sur un bloc notes. Ben vous pouvez écrire sur un bloc notes, l'écriture automatique
c'est hyper bien, c'est hyper libérateur, c'est vachement chouette. Vous pouvez dessiner, même si vous ne savez pas dessiner, on s'en fout !
Vous pouvez faire des origamis,
vous pouvez faire plein de trucs, je suis pas votre daronne non plus, mais, vous allez trouver des idées. Votre regard, il va peut-être s'arrêter
sur un bouquin, sur une bd, sur un truc que vous avez jamais lu. Bah ...
ouvrez le, feuilletez ... hein ... et puis vous verrez bien si ça vous plaît.
Il va peut-être s'arrêter juste pas sur votre four et ben c'est le moment de faire un gratin de nouilles aux pattes ou un truc
comme ça. Bref, vous allez forcément trouver quelque chose.
Et de toute façon si vous trouvez pas tout de suite c'est pas grave, parce que mon autre conseil, c'est de
picorer. Alors, c'est un peu chelou dit comme ça, mais quand quelqu'un arrive pas trop à manger ...
le conseil qu'on lui donne, C'est de fractionner ses repas, c'est à dire de manger régulièrement
des petites quantités, au lieu de faire genre deux ou trois gros repas.
Et bah là vous faites pareil avec vos activités, vous variez vous fait plein de choses différentes, vous essayer des trucs, déjà ça,
ça va faire passer le temps, et puis évidemment si à un moment vous tombez sur un truc qui vous plaît,
vous continuez et puis vous recommencez les jours d'après. C'est le moment de tenter des trucs, c'est le moment
d'oser. On a dit qu'on se foutait la paix avec la culpabilité.
Eh ben on ose aussi, lançons-nous, si vous avez envie de danser en slip dans votre salon,
vous dansez en slip dans votre salon. Qui va vous juger ? Moi ? Non ...
Le confinement, l'inactivité, l'inertie, tout ça. On en avait parlé dans la dernière vidéo,
c'est des choses qui sont bonnes, ni pour la santé mentale, ni pour la santé physique.
Donc n'hésitez pas à retourner et choper quelques petits conseils pour rester en bonne santé, parce que, on sera très content d'être en forme
quand on va sortir.
Parce que ça sera peut-être pas tout à fait comme on a imaginé, ça sera quand même vachement mieux que maintenant.
On sera hyper content et on sera joyeux de pouvoir en profiter en pleine forme, en pleine santé. Hein ?
Et puis pensez à tout ce qui apaise
physiquement, de façon immédiate.
Vous pouvez prendre un bain, si vous avez une baignoire, une douche, ça peut ... ça peut marcher aussi.
Euh... vous pouvez faire de la méditation,
des exercices de respiration abdominale ou de cohérence cardiaque,
des séances d'auto hypnose,
de sophrologie,
à base de lâcher prise etc... Il y a plein d'appli, il y'a plein de vidéos, en plus en ce moment il y en a pas
mal qui sont gratuites sur sur internet. Donc
cherchez, fouinez, vous allez trouver. Vous avez compris, le secret c'est, d'accepter
le fait que, on sait pas. Qu'on ne peut pas trop prévoir, on peut pas trop anticiper, donc de vivre dans
l'instant présent
et se laisser guider par ses envies et son plaisir.
Attention ça veut pas dire devenir complètement égoïste et complètement auto centré, mais ça veut dire, déjà,
réussir à être bien avec soi même. Parce que en ce moment, plus que jamais, on a vraiment besoin de ça.
Après c'est clair que, un autre moyen d'être bien avec soi-même et d'être bien tout court, c'est de s'occuper aussi un petit peu des autres.
Juste en prenant des nouvelles,
en témoignant un petit peu de soutien à des gens qui sont en difficulté, en "small talkant", en rigolant avec les potes ça fait toujours du
bien aux autres et à soi, ou en rendant des services. Que ce soit aux gens de notre cercle proche,
à nos voisins et pourquoi pas, si on a la ressource et qu'on se sent, à des gens complètement
inconnus. Il ya plein de gens qui ont besoin d'aide en ce moment. Le paradoxe c'est qu'on n'a jamais été aussi seul qu'en ce moment,
mais en même temps on n'a jamais eu autant besoin des autres.
C'est un petit peu vrai tout le temps, mais là en ce moment c'est
particulièrement exacerbée. Bah !
DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui, on se retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles vidéos. En attendant ... "prenez soin de vous,
prenons soin les uns des autres." Euh ... ça va Manu ? Je suis venu faire le kéké pendant ton allocution moi ? Non hein ?
En plus c'est pas comme ça qu'on dit, c'est, prenez soin de vous et prenez soin des autres, mettez vous bien et surtout ...
portez vous bien !
Le sans-gêne du mec quoi